[Music]
foreign
Drex here from drexfactor POI sharing
with you the love of boy spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
a couple weeks ago I uploaded a video of
myself performing an anti-brid combo
that got a lot of attention and a lot of
requests for me to show how all the
different transitions I'm using in at
work so
your wish is my command but before we
dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
Ultra POI for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinski and Becca becklenen thank you
both so much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission alright so let's
get this rolling here let me show you
the original combo it involves me
starting off with a cap vs pendulum and
doing a quick transition over to
isolation versus cat eye another
transition into isolation versus cat eye
and another transition into isolation
versus cat eye as I go back and forth
like this I also have the option to
switch back into pendulum versus cap but
now switching up which hand is doing
which
so how is that funky moment where I'm
keeping the POI together through the
center working what exactly is going on
there so these kind of anti-bred tricks
and transitions are stuff that I've been
doing for the better part of the decade
if not longer and by the way if the word
anti-brid is Greek to you I will go
ahead and leave a link to a playlist of
tutorials that I've done on the topic
down in the description but for those of
you who are really Keen to understand
how this is going there are two pieces
that are really really essential to have
the first are linear isolations and the
second one are point isolations and
really the two of these different POI
tricks have a lot in common in that
we're having movements where the hand is
moving a lot and we're trying to
restrict the movement to the POI head
they're also real tricky when it comes
to playing around with gravity like if
you try to do a point isolation and
bring your hand all the way around
there's inevitably a point where gravity
wants to pick back up that POI head and
make your life difficult so Point
isolations tend to happen when the hand
is going over the POI head and linear
isolations tend to be a little bit more
successful when we're letting gravity do
the work for us of letting the POI Head
Drop okay so how do these pieces of the
puzzle go together let's start off with
our first trick here this is pendulum
versus cap my right hand is performing a
cap my left hand is performing a
pendulum and I have my left hand even
with my shoulder so I can keep the
relationship between my right hand and
my left POI head even it creates that
lovely little optical illusion that
makes anti-brid so cool so the first
thing we need to watch out for here is
that moment where both my left hand POI
and my right hand are departing over
from my left hand side here now normally
as I'm performing this cap I am just
simply performing an anti-spin pedal
down below but I do something here that
is going to change the way the momentum
of this is working just a hair I'm going
to try as hard as I can not to just do a
petal at the bottom but to actually let
my POI Head Drop straight down my center
line now once I've done this it also
means it's going to come straight up my
Center Line like
so now when I bring my right hand over
to my right hand side it's usually
pointed straight out to the right but by
making this little tweak it's now coming
straight up my Center Line and my hand
is still aligned with the opposite POI
head okay so we got to this position
where we have the two point even with
our hands and our right hand is still
left to the right our left hand is about
on Center Line our next move is to take
both the right hand and the left POI
head
up and over to the left hand side here's
how we're going to do that the left hand
as it's going back and forth like this
we're going to give it just a little bit
of extra oomph so it does a spin above
our hand over to the left it's very very
important if we look at it from our
perspective it looks like it is spinning
counterclockwise that is it drops down
around to the right and then up and over
back to the left what the right hand is
doing it is going to do that linear
isolation and then as it comes straight
up our Center Line our right hand is
going to go over it in a point isolation
like so that is the key to making this
work so to see all that together we go
back and forth back and forth and I'm
going to drop down and take it around
like so
it takes a little bit of prep well it
takes a lot of practice in order to get
this to look as clean as possible but
the points that I'm trying to hit are
making sure I get that horizontal line
right here when my right hand is
straight out to the right it's trying to
make sure that my right hand and my left
POI are moving in unison over top and of
course I want to nail that same
horizontal line over on my left hand
side with my right hand Reaching Across
okay so we have found our transition we
can take our hands up and over and
arrive in this place over on our left
hand side where we have this anti-brit
alignment between our hands and POI so
what comes next the answer is anything
that you can think of that can include
this alignment to the hand and POI right
here but I personally have two things
that I really like to do out of this
transition that I'll show you here the
first quite honestly is just to go back
to the trick that I interrupted when I
was performing that transition and take
it right back into pendulum versus cap
like so how does this work basically you
take that moment when you come over to
the left hand side here and treat it
like the other side of the trick that
you just did so as I'm performing this
linear isolation straight up and doing
the point isolation over I can drop back
into a linear isolation straight down
and then treat that like the edge of
that bottom part of the petal the whole
thing looks like this
and then all I need do with my left hand
is switch into a static spin for a
moment and then drop back into a
pendulum altogether that looks like this
as we go around boom we drop back into
the trick
boom we drop back into the trick the
only thing tricky about this really
aside from the fact that you're doing
linear isolate linear isolations and
point isolations is that you're picking
up a lot of acceleration as that right
hand POI is going straight down your
Center Line so it can take a little bit
of effort to pull back into that cap and
not have this look like it's utter chaos
the other option which is the one that I
showed off in that video is to do a
transition into cat eye versus isolation
not only does this absorb some of that
momentum but it also plays around with
the alignment of going back and forth
from a pattern where the hand path is
two POI lengths across to a pattern
where it's only one POI length across
and what that looks like is as my right
hand and left POI head go over the
momentum is such that my right POI head
in hand want to drop and my left POI
wants to keep going counterclockwise so
so I let them the only trick is that I
bring my left hand up as this is
happening while my right hand goes down
and that of course keeps the anti-brit
alignment and specifically my right hand
align with my left POI and I can then
pull them back around into that
isolation versus cat eye that whole
transition is going to look like this
going up and around and over so as I'm
performing this isolation versus cat eye
over on my left hand side I have access
to another point in which the two POI
come up and are parallel and align with
each of my hands which means that I can
use this in the same way that I did over
on this side and bring both of the POI
and the entire pattern over to my left
hand side the only difference now I've
switched up which hand I'm going to be
using for my cat eye it is now my left
hand and if it worked on the left side
it'll also work on the right side I can
find that moment when the POI are coming
up together send them back over and
switch back into isolation versus cat
eye over on my right side I can
literally just go back and fourth
between the two sides using this trick
so all told I go from my pendulum versus
cap take it up and over switch into
isolation versus cat eye take it up and
over isolation versus cat eye take it up
and over isolation versus cat eye I can
just go add infinitum on this but
ultimately I usually just switch back
into cap versus pendulum at some point
and switch it to left hand doing the cap
instead of the right now and I think it
looks pretty cool so there you go I
think this is a pretty cool looking
transition and I would love to see some
of the creative things that you all out
there can do with it yourselves so
please upload some videos of yourself
playing around with this to Instagram or
Tick Tock and tag me I would love to
check them out if you got anything out
of this video please make sure to like
comment share and subscribe both to help
other people find it and to help my
channel grow
foreign
this video would not be possible without
the kind support of all of these lovely
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people who sit down in the description
help to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you one and all for your very generous
support and if you out there watching
would like to support my work and are
not currently doing so you can sign up
to do it over at patreon.com
drexfactorpoi there you can get access
to a whole host of awesome rewards and
even better you'll be helping me out in
my mission to bring POI spinning and
flow Arts to the whole wide world so go
check that out please and thank you do
you want to see more anti-brid stuff
from me let me know down in the comments
in the meantime I will go ahead and
include a link to a playlist of other
videos I've done on anti-bred technique
down in the description as well as up
here on screen if you're watching on
YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you might like this top
video based upon your past viewing
habits so maybe give that a look as well
thanks so much for watching make sure to
flow today and I'll see you with a new
video real soon
peace